bonsoir donc gérard ces gars 1 le
responsable du projet sco rêve pilote
innovations des systèmes de transport
intelligents pour renault on s'intéresse
aux véhicules du futur avec vous ce
qu'au rêve qui signifie système
coopératif routier expérimental français
voila voila c'est en fait des clochers
qui permettra à terme de voir les
véhicules communiquer entre notamment à
quoi tout cela va-t-il servir mais la
première chose c'est la sécurité
routière parce que la commission
européenne a fixé des objectifs très
ambitieux 0 morts sur les routes en 2050
zéro blessés graves et donc il faut bien
trouver des innovations qui nous
permette d'aboutir à ces enjeux c'est de
ces défis en fait important il ya des
dispositifs en test actuellement quels
sont ces dispositifs à l'ordre et qui
sont testés on a des véhicules qui sont
équipés donc il communique en est qu'ils
coopèrent entre eux en fait en
permanence et ses véhicules qu opère
aussi avec des bords de route donc c'est
des petites boîtes qu'on positionne un
peu partout le long des routes de façon
à collecter des données puis a envoyé
des consignes aux conducteurs ont fait 1
c'est à dire que s'affiche comme sur son
gps actuellement des signalisations
précise sur le trafic sur l'a alors il
ya deux catégories de communication et à
la communication véhicules véhicules
donc les cultes commis directement entre
eux et par exemple quand un véhicule
détecte un danger il le signale à tous
les autres et donc automatiquement dans
les eaux de la seconde qui suit en fait
on veut on voit s'afficher la
signalisation du danger c'est un
véhicule s'arrête brusquement à la
dorsale
agressé le véhicule immobilisé c'est
l'accident c'est les chaussées
glissantes par exemple quand un véhicule
glisse sur la route il peut le détecter
automatiquement avec son aspect est le
signal aux autres alors il en bouteille
h il ya beaucoup de
danger comme ça qu'ils peuvent être
signalés immédiatement
par ailleurs les ut bord de route elles
peuvent renvoyer des consignes aux
conducteurs sur ben devlin est
recommandé par exemple quand on a un
accident quand tu as une route fermée ou
sur des limites de vitesse contextuel
par exemple on a une chaussée glissante
ont réduit la vitesse ou non une
pollution importante donc ont valu la
vitesse et donc ça permet aux conseils
généraux en fête ou aux opérateurs
routiers de façon générale d'être en
relation directe avec les conducteurs
matin on va peut-être voir des images
justement dès qu'ils sont et qui ont été
réalisés puisque en ce moment le
dispositif est testé vous allez pouvoir
voir de quoi il s'agit c'est tout
simplement ça se présente sous forme
d'une tablette en fait c'est comme ça
oui ben allal actuellement seront pas ce
parce que c'est pas intégrer encore dans
les véhicules quand elle sera intégrée à
ce niveau de l'interface homme-machine
du conducteur donc aujourd'hui on a mis
une tablette samsung et 7 pouces en fait
un tout à fait standard et cette
tablette est connecté à une idée
télématique qui communiquent il est
permis la communication avec les
véhicules et avaient qualité bord de
route et qui participe actuellement à ce
projet ce qu'aurait fait justement vous
représentez renault oui donc c'est quand
même un oui il ya 21 partenaires dont
par exemple psa et notre concurrent avec
qui on travaille mais il ya aussi
cofiroute l'un qui gère des autres
routes en particulier l'a86 il ya plein
de petits pme qui développe des
logiciels on a des unités des instituts
de recherche comme une star à satory où
tout symbolique le département des
yvelines très fortement voyais
absolument donc c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que le conseil général
gentiment nous non seulement
subventionne le projet mais a mis à
disposition la route nationale
départementale 91 et nous permet
d'expérimenter en face et systèmes laas
est en phase d'expérimentation ça veut
dire que les constructeurs comme renault
comme psa par la suite peugeot citroën
vont utiliser ces technologies ces
dispositifs oui c'est quasiment déjà
décidé il y aura un déploiement de cette
technologie qui commencera probablement
des mileux 1 en 2015 par
un certain nombre de constructeurs
deauville en nous et quelle sa part
comprendre par une phase pilote parce
que notre projet quand même petit
comparé à certains autres projets aux
états unis ou en allemagne par exemple
mais d'ici quelques années ou et racé
voitures sur les routes on va parler de
ce qui se fait justement à l'étranger
rester avec nous mais pour l'instant on
va continuer à parler automobile du
futur on va regarder ce reportage de la
rédaction pour découvrir ces autres
entreprises qui développent des projets
avec l'aide notamment du conseil général
des yvelines leurs prototypes ont été
exposé au public vendredi dernier à
versailles
laisser sa voiture se garer toute seule
ou l'appeler à la sortie d'un restaurant
pour qu'elle vienne vous chercher vous
en rêviez c'est aujourd'hui possible des
prototypes de véhicules automatiques
étaient présentés au public à versailles
vendredi dernier à l'origine quatre
entreprises yvelinoise plein d'idées qui
ont remporté l'appel à projets du
conseil général véhicules intelligents
ville du futur mais une voiture
intelligente c'est quoi exactement
petite démonstration en images mohamed
conduit son véhicule à l'entrée du
parking grâce à cette borne l'automobile
se met en mode automatique et repère
quelle place est libre maintenant le
véhicule conduire en automatique en
suivant les lignes au sol
autre exemple avec le projet taxi colle
une navette hybride qui peut fonctionner
en mode automatique ou avec un
conducteur
particularité un chauffeur peut conduire
un convoi de cinq véhicules reliés à ses
côtés le projet 1001 autres véhicules
hybrides destinés au transport de
marchandises dans des lieux dédiés comme
les hangars un système d'auto partage
permet de répartir la flotte selon les
besoins sans intervention humaine et
enfin quatrième et dernier projet la
ligne kengo une voiture électrique
futuriste un volant qu on imaginerait
plutôt dans un avion et de multiples
innovations high-tech
une autre façon machin que vous pouvez
revoir une chine qui est tactile
mais ensuite en mode autonome c'est ça
qui fait l'intérêt de la voiture c'est
que la voiture la banquette sans se
retourner à 180 degrés et on a
finalement l'environnement le conducteur
totalement participer à la convivialité
de la voiture en créant cet espace un
conducteur et passager se font face et
peuvent sur cet écran géant visualiser
la route regarder un film ou encore
aller sur les réseaux sociaux comme les
autres véhicules elle se gare toute
seule et un bras automatique et la
branche à une borne de recharge
rassemblés sous la bannière du conseil
général ces quatre véhicules du futur
ont bénéficié d'un sérieux coup de pouce
ce sont des entreprises installées dans
les yvelines c'est bien entendu la
condition sinequanone et notre aide a
été atteint le niveau de 3 millions
d'euros pour ces pour ces entreprises et
on leur a porté outre l'argent une
reconnaissance à travers la présence
d'un stand du conseil général des
yvelines au salon de genève qui en
termes de calendrier le premier grand
salon international
chaque année dans le contexte actuel
assez véhicule n'aurait peut-être pas vu
le jour les yvelines reste aujourd'hui
le premier département automobile le
secteur emploie quarante cinq mille
personnes
quel regard vous portez sur ces
différents projets qui sont développés
vous voyez ça comme une émulation ou de
la concurrence non non c'est plutôt une
concurrence au contraire c'est du tout
une émulation et on a nous mène
d'ailleurs des expérimentations qui vont
dans ce sens là donc tout toutes les
modes d'alimentation sont des biens
venus pratiquer la voiture automatique
ainsi on veut éviter si on lui faire
atteindre 2,0 morts sur les routes il
faudra que les voitures prennent le
contrôle d'elle-même au moment où il ya
un risque d'accident ça serait exagéré
dans un avenir plutôt proche ben il faut
le temps que il faut que la voiture
aucune déception totale de son
environnement à travers des
communications accès aux deux véhicules
ou des kits des capteurs ont fait un des
radars des choses comme ça et ça va
prendre un homme bien une vingtaine
d'années avant d'avoir
zéro mort et zéro blessés graves sur les
routes en fait on parle de ses véhicules
du futur l'automobile est en période de
crise comme de nombreux secteurs en
france il connaît vos difficultés
malheureusement ceci dit toutes les
innovations qui sont développés en ce
moment sur lesquels vous travaillez ça
peut être une idée pour sortir de la
crise oui je pense que ça fait pas
continuer mais si les ratios l'image
c'est extrêmement important de continuer
à innover ça va créer des emplois à
créer des nouveaux secteurs d'activités
un côtes si on installe les idées bord
de route il faudra fabriquer ses étés
bordeaux tifra les installer il faudrait
opérer et c'est donc tout ça c'est
effectivement ses créateurs d'emplois
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
promouvoir et mais les plus difficiles
ou plus facile au contraire d'obtenir
des budgets pour développer toutes ces
solutions par exemple pour pour ce corps
f dont on parlait tout à l'heure que
vous pilotez pour sa mise en place il a
été difficile d'obtenir des fonds ça a
été assez difficile
bon c'est lié à l'époque où on a
commencéà pauvres pour reposer le projet
ces innovations n'était pas connue en
fait c'est ce qui nous manque un petit
peu c'est il faut arriver à sensibiliser
les principaux acteurs et en partie les
financiers sur des innovations et il ya
quoi qu'au bout d'un certain temps qu'on
arrive à faire comprendre ce qu'on veut
faire et pouvoir supporter en fait donc
ses centres pays bas ça semble aller
plus vite en fait descendre que les
autres pays que ce soit en allemagne aux
usa il est moins de difficultés pour
vaincre en fait sur l'intérêt d'une
innovation sur ce dispositif sur lequel
vous travaillez avec ce qu'au rêve qui
permettront aux rappels de véhicules de
communiquer avec les autres véhicules
ces véhicules intelligents ça permettra
de détecter les difficultés sur la route
notamment par exemple à l'étranger en
allemagne aussi travaillent sur ce genre
de 10 par oui ils travaillent et ils ont
commencé deux ans avant nous et ils ont
un gros projet enfin qu'il fait à peu
près 10 fois ce qu'aurait fait dans la
région de francfort et aux etats unis
c'est encore pire puisqu'ils ont plus de
3000 véhicules
dans le michigan dans cette critique au
père de cette façon là en fait et donc
effectivement l'allemagne où les
américains sont plus en avance que nous
et les asiatiques sont pas loin derrière
fait alors comment on fait la différence
dans ce cas là bas on essaye de
rattraper progressivement et puis de
convaincre en fait que ce soit nos
patrons interne ou les financeurs que
c'est il ya un potentiel d'innovation
important derrière en fait un des sacs
et qui souhaitent de faire pour le
développement de votre projet justement
la prochaine étape la l'expérimentation
est en cours des phases de test grandeur
nature et ensuite oui alors là
effectivement on a une flotte qui est
assez réduite de l'ordre de 25 à 30
véhicules avec psa c'est pas suffisant
parce que les véhicules ont peu de
chance de se croiser en fait un pour
communiquer entre eux donc maintenant on
envisage de concentrer sur des zones
bien définies plusieurs milliers de
véhicules d'ici deux trois ans qu'on
2015-2016 de façon à vraiment tester le
système aussi bien techniquement mais
aussi regarder l'aspect nos techniques
c'est dire l'impact sur le coût de la
conduite sur le conducteur mais aussi
l'acceptabilité clients effectivement
comment le client va accepter ces
nouveaux services en fait l'ajustement
qu'attendent les clients quels sont les
nouveaux services éventuellement qu'ils
attendent sur les voitures de vue à
suivre quelles innovations
souhaitez-vous nous sommes allés vous
posez la question aux micros trottoirs
qu'elle utilise pas de l'essence ok ça
tout seul à des questions de sécurité
saïx déjà qu'on est fatigué une sorte d'
alerte outre une facilité pour faire des
créneaux je pense que ce serait le
lemieux accueil rouleau pitt gasoil un
distributeur de petites choses sympas
manger ou à boire je sais pas pourquoi
pas des massages connecter ma musique
que je suis mon portable dans ma voiture
je sais pas au bout de quelques
plusieurs kilomètres des fonds d'un peu
mal aux deux forces devraient fait ainsi
donc dès qu'il y aurait des fauteuils
qui permettrait d'éviter ce genre de
problème niveau sécurité qui freine
toute seule qui prévient sur son sort
comme ça si j'ai quelque chose qui
n'existait pas je vais garder pour moi
ces idées lancées jamais que je peux les
brevetés
sécurité 1 c'est bien il ya des
automobilistes qui sont sérieux ils font
attention les créneaux aussi ça c'est
important que nous à manger et des
massages allez vous travailler sur ça à
manger pas trop et les matches oui les
massages à des voitures quand même
acquis qui mate qui relatent en fait les
conducteurs ou les passagers venant du
tout même si la sécurité qu'il y avait
une vraie prise de conscience aussi des
automobilistes mais il y avait une
attente oui bien sûr il ya pratiqué sur
l'aspect endormissement ou vigilance du
conducteur c'est quelque chose qui est
important en terme d'accidentologie au
fait merci d'être venu nous parler de ce
projet sur le plateau de ces véhicules
du futur communiquant avec ce qu'aurait
fait il existe aussi un site internet 1
d'ailleurs ce qu'aurait point fr pour
ceux qui veulent en savoir encore plus
merci je vous donne une dernière info
qui concerne le domaine de l'automobile
vendredi dernier le groupe renault a
annoncé via son président sa décision de
produire sur l' usine de flins sur seine
à partir de 2016 la future génération de
nissan micra objectif la production sur
place de 82000 véhicules en 2017